[Musique]
j'ai presque terminé ce sont les anciens
un signe il est écrit rbf pour forces de
police royale de la barbade
depuis le 1er décembre dernier
nous sommes devenus une république nous
sommes maintenant le service de police
de la barbade
l'inspecteur rooney in his vient de
recevoir les nouvelles épaulettes de la
police barbadienne aujourd'hui il les
présente à son équipe une étoile orné du
trident de la barbade à la place de la
couronne britannique
sur les uniformes des policiers tous les
attributs de la monarchie britannique
vont disparaître mais pour l'inspecteur
rhône et nice le changement est surtout
symbolique mais quand ce n'est pas parce
que nous avons changé de nom que nous
allons oublier toute notre riche
histoire nous voulons la conserver tous
les policiers ils sont encore très
attachés depuis le 30 novembre dernier
elizabeth d'angleterre n'est plus reine
de la barbade cette ancienne colonie des
antilles britanniques et devenue la plus
jeune république au monde depuis
l'indépendance de la barbade en 1966 la
question républicaine a de nombreuses
fois été posée mais jamais résolu il
aura finalement suffi d'une étincelle
sauvé c'est selon c'est ici qu'ils
étaient la statue de lord nelson
des centaines d'années d'histoire la
statue de l'amiral nelson figure de l'
empire colonial britannique a longtemps
trôné sur la place des héros de la
capitale bridgetown voyez il ya des
graffitis c'était un lieu très
controversé après des études d'histoire
à l'étranger alex jones revient
travailler à la barbade en 2019 vous
savez c'était l'époque du mouvement
black l'animateur et tout le monde
s'intéressait aux injustices raciales il
y avait une vraie volonté de comprendre
j'ai lancé la pétition autour du 7 juin
2020 je pense j'ai créé un message je
suis allé sur change.org est gelée
publié
le lendemain matin je me suis réveillé
ce avait explosé il y avait des
centaines de signatures et j'ai reçu des
messages du monde entier la pétition
d'alex jones finit par se retrouver sur
le bureau de la première ministre mia
amants maudits et le 20 novembre 2020 la
statue de l'amiral nelson tombe aux
mains vides et jour-là donc j'en ai
profité pour ba être sûr d'avoir un
souvenir
vraiment c'était un moment historique
quand on était petits on nous parlait
tout le temps de cette statue et jamais
je n'aurais pensé que cela arriverait
vraiment et que je serai celui qui l'a
fait tomber
un an plus tard un autre symbole du
passé colonial disparaît avec la
proclamation de la république de la
barbade suite à ce changement de régime
la première ministre annonce des
élections anticipées
au siège du parti de me i'm only les
résultats arrivent les uns après les
autres tard dans la nuit tous les votes
ont été comptés la population a
massivement renouvelé son soutien a mis
à votre lit comme en 2018 son parti
remporte tous les sièges au parlement
la plus jeune république parlementaire
au monde
a renforcé son engagement
en faveur des plus hauts standards de la
démocratie
la proclamation de la république n'a pas
rencontré de réelles oppositions mais ce
changement symbolique n'est qu'une étape
vers la construction d'une identité
nationale la barbade porte toujours les
stigmates d'un passé douloureux ici au
sud de lille sur cette ancienne
plantation près de 600 esclaves ont été
enterrés dans une fosse commune glace à
chamonix fin
sur ce site l'historien kevin farmer
supervise la construction d'un mémorial
de l'esclavagé
le mémorial va être construit juste là
sur cette colline pour faire face à la
fosse commune
maintenant que nous sommes une
république c'est très important de
célébrer et de commémorer un des rares
lieux qui témoignent du passé je n'ai
pas juste conscience de mon passé je
veux m'en inspirer je veux le comprendre
notre histoire est source de fierté il
n'y a aucune honte à avoir
elizabeth ii règne encore dans huit
états de la caraïbe pour beaucoup
d'entre eux la monarchie britannique est
appelée à disparaître en jamaïque 55% de
la population se dit aujourd'hui
favorable à la république